Oh,
here we go,
fast.
You going to fight for in it.
I'm not saying he's fat,
but when he jumps in the yard,
he gets stuck.
Jim,
Gary,
you know,
everybody that you know,
including yourself is a mind reader.
At least we all think we are.
We act that way because really there's
no other way to act.
We see someone do something like look at
a camera and attribute to that act and
invisible mental state,
a desire and intention of feeling like
disbelief.
This is called the theory of mind,
but there's a paradox at the heart of
this ability that we all have because
while we know that body language conveys
meaning and that we can interpret that
meaning and even be roughly correct a
good amount of the time,
we also know that it's impossible to see
the whole picture that we can
misinterpret and be fooled because both
of those things have happened to us.
I was just wondering,
uh,
Niceville with Lee,
would you?
Let's come in Virginia with me.
I haven't split up with him as a friend.
So I didn't mean as a friend
paradox in the theory of mind,
our attributes of thoughts to action and
our knowledge of the unreliability in
that drives all of us to perform
ourselves so that we can try to shape
other people's theories of our mind and
it's this performance and the reading of
this performance that the office created
by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant
spotlights so well.
The people who work at wornum hog
comprise a spectrum of competence on
this scale.
On one side you have tim and Don who are
quite sensitive mind readers,
able to navigate the environment of the
office with a strong sense of what
others are feeling.
And on the other side you have David,
Brent,
and Gareth who are really,
really weak
mind readers.
If you do go the way Tim and you expect
me to go in there afterwards,
make sure he wears a condom.
In the case of Gareth,
it may actually be that he's unable to
read others.
Jervis explored this idea again,
years later with Derek,
a character who fall somewhere on the
autism spectrum,
a condition that's marked by inherent
difficulties with theory of mind,
but in David Brent,
we have a character so invested in the
performance of himself that he's blocked
his own access to other's feelings and I
think Brent could become more receptive
and there are rare but achingly poignant
flashes of that in the series.
Chris,
what don't you fuck off
to really do that would require
compromising his self image,
which is clearly something that he's not
willing to do.
The irony is that Brent can't see that a
weak theory of mind always makes for a
week.
Self-Performance.
You can't brute force your preferred
personality onto another's
consciousness.
It takes two to build an identity.
Indeed.
This is what makes tim the most
successful performer of all on the show
and the clearest evidence of this is the
cruel but hilarious way that he toys
with Gareth,
could you give a man a lethal blow for?
I was forced to.
I could if it was absolutely necessary.
He's able to map Gareth's mental state
so well and take advantage of his weak
theory of mine that he can ridicule him
without Gareth even knowing that it's
going on.
This is a kind of psychic superpower and
we all use it when we tell someone,
for example,
a white lie,
we're trying to decode that person's
mental state so that our performance of
the lie will be successfully received.
In other words,
a believable performance is one that
reflects back at your partner,
something that's in support of their own
performance of themselves.
What makes the show even more
impressive?
I think an absolutely true to life is
the way that it handles the other side
of the paradox.
No matter where the characters fall on
that spectrum of mind reading or
performance,
none are spared from mistakes.
It's this essential defect in the theory
of mine that's a cause of deep anxiety
for all of us,
and every time that unreliability is
violently revealed to us,
the world for a brief moment becomes
jibberish and the people around us
opaque
because this is the only tool that we
have,
and for the most part it's done like
breathing is done without conscious
attention,
so when it fails,
there's just no recourse.
It's the unflinching focus on these
failures that made the office
revolutionary.
A lot of people say that cringe humor
like this is hard to watch,
and certainly it is,
but in the same way that under our
confidence in theory of mind lies and
anxiety,
I think that under our cringing,
there's actually a deep feeling of
relief.
Cringe.
Humor privileges the moments when body
language speaks in a way that is totally
transparent.
In that moment,
the embarrassment is not only palpable,
it's also palpably honest.
It can't be doubted.
It's a kind of trauma,
a rupture that discloses a real moment
of
connection.
Look,
David,
I don't.
I've changed my mind.
I don't want redundancy.
I don't want not,
haven't signed anything so well,
unfortunately.
Not really up to you.
Sorry.
Alright.
Then when I'm asking please.
That might be redundant.
I don't think the show would be nearly
as effective if it wasn't cast as a fake
documentary as opposed to simply
watching the characters fail and
embarrass themselves.
As an omniscient observer.
The employees of the office are aware of
being filmed,
which is to say that they're aware of
you,
but not only performing for one another,
they're performing for us.
This is the phenomenon of the
documentary and the documentary.
You can observe human behavior,
mind reading you and performing at you
without having to reflect back your own
performance.
You can be alone with someone,
Jason Merchant exploit the situation to
activate our empathy in a uniquely
powerful way so that when you laugh at
the office,
it's a laugh that rings out in the heart
of moment of cringeworthy truth.
Everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I really wish I could be recording this
on a camera right now,
but it's a little bit too late and you
know,
my office is so really incomplete in Los
Angeles and it's,
it's just,
it's just very frustrating.
Um,
thank you so much to squarespace for
sponsoring this video.
I'm really fortunate to have squarespace
helping to fund this channel.
They make a really,
really great product.
It's a professional,
sleek looking,
intuitive websites that you don't need
to know coding to make.
I'm just really easy to do and you can
get a free domain if you sign up for a
year and you can start that free trial
today@squarespace.com.
And if you do and you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
So thanks squarespace for that.
And also,
thank you guys.
I'll see you next Wednesday.
And have you had.